REALIZES PEOPLE ARE GETTING
ITCHY AND WANT TO BE PRODUCTIVE
WHILE TRYING TO BE SAFE.
LET’S BRING IN ONE OF THE BEST
IN THE BUSINESS THE ONE LEANING
ON THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE
PANDEMIC DR. DEBORAH BIRX WHITE
HOUSE CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE
COORDINATOR WHO DOESN’T SEEM TO
NEED ANY REST.
I WATCHED YOU LAST NIGHT
OUTDOORS AND WATCH YOU SUNDAY ON
EVERY SUNDAY SHOW AND BACK WITH
US ON TUESDAY MORNING.
I THINK I’M GOING TO PUT NEW FOR
A RAISE.
I WILL SUPPLY THE PAPERWORK A
LITTLE BIT LATER, DR. BIRX.
LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY SURPRISED ME WITH THE
TESTING.
GETTING WALMART AND CVS AND
OTHERS TO RAMP IT UP.
IN THE BACK OF MY MIND IS WHAT
YOU SAID ON SUNDAY THAT WITHOUT
ANY MAJOR INNOVATIONS, WE’RE NOT
GOING TO GET TESTING WHERE WE
WANT IT TO BE.
IN THE NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE.
DID YOU NOT ANTICIPATE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR GETTING INVOLVED
IN THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS
YESTERDAY?
>> THE PRIVATE SECTOR HAS BEEN
INVOLVED.
IT WAS THE MAGNITUDE OF
INVOLVEMENT.
I MEAN, I THINK WE HAVE REALLY
UNDERSTOOD THAT YOU HAVE GOT TO
BRING THE TEST TO THE COMMUNITY.
WHETHER IT’S DRIVE-THRU.
WHETHER IT’S WALK THROUGH.
THE COMMUNITY HAS TO FEEL LIKE
TESTS ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
SO JUST HAVING IT AT HOSPITALS
OR CLINICS WAS NOT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH.
SO THAT PART OF THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO EXPAND
COMMUNITY TESTING.
STEVE: DR. BIRX, YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
STATISTICS AND YOU HAVE AS WELL.
I WAS READING IN THE "NEW YORK
POST" SCOTT ATLAS FROM THE
HOOVER INSTITUTE WROTE A OP-ED
ABOUT LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS.
OF THE -- OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DESIGNATED COVID, ABSOLUTELY
COVID DEATHS INVESTIGATE NEW NEW
YORK.
99.2% HAD UNDERLYING ISSUES.
SO IF 99% HAD UNDERLYING ISSUES,
THE CHANCES OF THE AVERAGE
PERSON, A HEALTHY PERSON GETTING
IT ARE SMALL.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
HAVE HEARD FROM MY FRIENDS ON
ZOOM AND WALKING AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD IS MAYBE THE
GOVERNMENT OVERDID IT IN CLOSING
EVERYTHING DOWN TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY WAS SAFE WHEN, IN
FACT, YOU JUST HAD TO PROTECT A
CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHIC.
>> I THINK THAT’S AN INTERESTING
IDEA.
I THINK WHO WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT VERY CAREFULLY IS THE
EXPLOSIVE NATURE OF THIS VIRUS.
AND I THINK IT’S HIGHLY
CONTAGIOUS.
AND SO EVEN IN PHASE 1.
WE HAVE ASKED EVERY GOVERNOR,
EVERY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL TO
ENSURE WHETHER YOU ARE INSIDE OR
OUTSIDE TO MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING WHEN YOU ARE IN A
PUBLIC PLACE AND TO HAVE A MASK
IF YOU CAN.
BECAUSE IT’S REALLY REALLY
CRITICAL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NEW YORK AREA
WHERE THEY COULD GET TO 2% OF
THE ENTIRE POPULATION INFECTED
OR HOSPITALIZED OR CLOSED TO
HOSPITALIZED OR SERIOUS ILLNESS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE MILD SYMPTOMS.
BUT I THINK WHAT YOU ARE REALLY
GETTING, TO DOES EVERYONE KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE AN UNDERLYING
CONDITION?
DO WE KNOW ALL THE UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS THAT ARE CRITICAL?
I THINK ADDING ASTHMA WAS
CRITICAL.
BUT ALSO HYPERTENSION.
EVEN MILD HYPERTENSION.
A LOT OF AMERICANS HAVE THAT.
AND SO I THINK THE CONVERSE OF
THAT IS HOW MANY AMERICANS
ACTUALLY HAVE EARLY SIGNS OF
EARLY DIABETES, EARLY
HYPERTENSION, ASTHMA?
A LOT OF AMERICANS DO.
SO WE HAD AN OBLIGATION TO
PROTECT ALL OF AMERICANS WHILE
WE CHECKED THE DATA.
HOW CONTAGIOUS THIS VIRUS IS AND
HOW RAPID THERE SPREAD AND HOW
TO TREAT IT WHEN PEOPLE GET TO
THE HOSPITALS.
AINSLEY: WE SEE SOME OF THESE
IMAGES OF THE BEACHES LIKE THE
ONES IN CALIFORNIA WHERE PEOPLE
ARE NOT SOCIAL DISTANCING.
FEW ARE WEARING MASKS.
YOU SEE THE BOARDWALKS WITH TONS
OF PEOPLE.
I KNOW SOME OF THESE ARE
FAMILIES AND THEY HAVE BEEN
TOGETHER FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY ARE OKAY.
BUT, NOT EVERYONE IS SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK IT WAS
TWO DAYS AGO YOU SAID WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT SOCIAL DISTANCING
THROUGH THE SUMMER.
WHAT ARE YOUR GUIDELINES TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT ARE
WATCHING RIGHT NOW?
>> I’M GLAD YOU MENTIONED THAT
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT AND EVEN IN PHASE 1 AND
PHASE 2.
WE HAVE ASKED PEOPLE WITH
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS AND
CO-MORBIDITIES TO CONTINUE TO
SHELTER OR SHELTER AS MUCH AS
THEY CAN.
AND THAT’S PART OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THEN EVERYBODY
WHO IS IN THOSE HOUSEHOLDS HAS
TO BE SCRUPULOUS IN THEIR
HYGIENE AND PROTECTION AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING WHILE THEY ARE
OUT.
AND THE REASON THIS HAS BECOME
MORE AND MORE IMPORTANT IS WE
ARE BEGINNING TO UNDERSTAND MORE
AND MORE THAT THERE MAY BE AN
INVERSE RELATIONSHIP FOR HOW
SEVERE THE DISEASE IS AND YOUR
AGE.
SO YOUNGER PEOPLE COULD ACTUALLY
BE INFECTED AND NOT KNOW THEY
ARE INFECTED.
AND UNINTENTIONALLY PASS THE
VIRUS ON.
SO THAT’S WHY WE NEED EVERYONE
TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND EVERYONE
TO TAKE CARE.
BRIAN: DR. BIRX, HOW DO YOU VIEW
THESE DAILY UPDATES?
FAUCI STATING THEY ARE GRUELING,
THEY LAST FOR AN HOUR AND A
HALF.
YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY INVOLVED IN A
POLITICAL SITUATION WHEN YOU ARE
UP THERE.
IT DOESN’T TAKE MUCH TO SEE THAT
IN THOSE QUESTIONS.
DO YOU EVER WONDER ABOUT THE
BENEFIT OF HAVING THEM AT THE
LENGTH THAT THEY’RE FOR YOU
PERSONALLY AND FOR THE PUBLIC TO
BE INFORMED?
DO YOU EVER WONDER IF WE ARE
ACTUALLY BENEFITING FROM THEM?
>> I THINK IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
COLLECTING DATA EVERY DAY AND
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
RESPOND TO THIS EPIDEMIC.
AND THEN PASSING ON INSIGHTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
EACH STATE IS SEEING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND HAS A DIFFERENT
BEST PRACTICE.
AND OUR JOB IS TO ENSURE THAT
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR’S CALL AND
THROUGH THOSE PRESS CONFERENCES
THAT PRESS BRIEF THAT WE
ACTUALLY ARE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
KEY NEW FINDINGS AND NEW INSIDES
THAT GOVERNORS AND STAYS HAVE
BROUGHT US AND CERTAINLY THAT WE
SEE IN THE DATA.
BRIAN: CAN I ASK YOU REAL
QUICK --
STEVE: ACTUALLY HEARING WHAT --
BRIAN: DR. BIRX, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT THOSE
BRIEFINGS?
>> I’M SORRY, I COULDN’T HEAR
YOU.
BRIAN: WOULD YOU LIKE TO CHANGE
ANYTHING ABOUT THOSE BRIEFINGS?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK I’M A
POWERPOINT KIND OF GAL.
I’M VERY DATA DRIVEN.
I REALLY LIKE TO USE THAT TIME
TO EDUCATE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO, YOU KNOW, IF I HAVE GOT A
GRAPH BEHIND ME, I’M
EXTRAORDINARILY HAPPY.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC --
THE MORE KNOWLEDGE THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC HAS ABOUT THIS EPIDEMIC,
WHERE IT IS ON A COUNTY BY
COUNTY DIALOGUE, IS REALLY
CRITICAL.
THE MORE COMMUNITIES KNOW, THE
MORE THEY CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
SO, I’M ALWAYS HAPPY WHEN WE CAN
DO GRAPHICS AND TALK TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STEVE: I STARTED TO SAY I ENJOY
SEEING THE BRIEFINGS WITH THE
LEADERS AT THE END OF THE DAY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
IT WAS GOOD TO SEE THE CEOs OF
THE TESTING’S AND BIG RETAILERS
YESTERDAY TALKING ABOUT THE
NATIONAL STRATEGY.
BUT, DR. BIRX, GOING BACK TO
WHAT AINSLEY HAD TALKED ABOUT
WITH YOU REGARDING SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND PARTICULARLY THE
IDEA OF WEARING MASK, WE HAD A
STORY ABOUT 20 MINUTES AGO THAT
APPARENTLY JETBLUE IS GOING TO
REQUIRE THE PASSENGERS TO WEAR
SOME SORT OF A FACE COVERING.
I’M JUST WONDERING GOING
FORWARD, HOW MUCH FACE COVERING
ARE WE GOING TO SEE?
I MEAN MY DAUGHTER WAS SUPPOSED
TO GET MARRIED THIS SATURDAY.
BUT THEY HAVE PUT OUT THE
WEDDING FOR THREE MONTHS.
THAT’S RIGHT, SALLY IS WATCHING
SOMEWHERE.
SHE IS GOING TO GET MARRIED IN
AUGUST NOW.
BUT, GOING FORWARD, YOU KNOW,
WILL PEOPLE AT THE WEDDING BE
WEARING FACE COVERINGS BECAUSE
THEY WILL BE DANCING AND THINGS
LIKE THAT?
GOING TO SPORTING EVENTS.
WILL PEOPLE BE IN STADIUM SEATS
WITH A FACE COVERINGS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK GOING FORWARD
AMERICA LOOKS LIKE.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THIS VIRUS.
WE KNOW THAT TALKING, SINGING,
CERTAINLY SNEEZING AND COUGHING
CAN PASS THE VIRUS ON TO OTHERS.
AND BECAUSE YOU CAN PASS IT WHEN
YOU ARE ASYMPTOMATIC, PEOPLE
DON’T KNOW THAT THEY ARE
INFECTED.
SO IF THERE IS VIRUS IN THE
COMMUNITY, OR YOU ARE GATHERING
PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT AREAS OF A
STATE WHERE THERE MAY BE STILL
RESIDUAL VIRUS AND NO VIRUS, IF
EVERYBODY WEARS A FACE MASK,
THEN YOU ARE PROTECTING THE
OTHER PERSON.
BECAUSE IT’S REALLY HAVING THE
ASYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS WEARING
MASKS BUT SINCE YOU DON’T KNOW
IF YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE, REALLY
EVERYONE NEEDS TO IN THOSE KIND
OF SOCIAL GATHERING SITUATIONS.
AS LONG AS THERE IS VIRUS STILL
IN THE COMMUNITY.
AINSLEY: DR. BIRX, JUST TO PIGGY
BACK ON WHAT BRIAN WAS SAYING.
YOU ARE VERY SMART.
YOU ARE UP THERE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
WE KNOW YOU ARE NOT GETTING ANY
SLEEP.
WE THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
WE ARE SORRY THAT SOMETIMES
POLITICS DOES PLAY A ROLE IN ALL
OF THIS.
I KNOW YOU JUST WANT TO GET THE
FACTS OUT THERE AND YOUR MEDICAL
POINTS ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THE POLITICS.
YOU CARE ABOUT EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN AND WE APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU ARE DOING.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
FALL.
WHAT ARE YOUR PREDICTIONS FOR
THE FALL?
I KNOW NEW YORK IS DIFFERENT
THAN CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
BUT, ARE YOU THINKING THAT -- I
KNOW AS YOU SAID WEDDINGS ARE
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT.
WE MIGHT BE WEARING MASKS AT
WEDDINGS IN THE FALL.
DO YOU THINK SCHOOLS WILL START
BACK UP AND HOW DO YOU THINK
THIS IS GOING TO CHANGE AMERICA
GOING FORWARD?
>> YOU KNOW.
IT’S A GREAT QUESTION.
NORMALLY, NORTHERN HEMISPHERE
RESPIRATORY DISEASES MOVE INTO
THE SOUTHERN HEMISPHERE DURING
THE SUMMER BECAUSE IT’S -- IT
WILL BE INTERESTING TO WATCH
AUSTRALIA, NEW ZEALAND, SOUTHERN
AFRICA AND CHILE AND ARGENTINA.
WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH THE VIRUS
HERE.
REALLY THOSE TWO PIECES TOGETHER
WILL DEFINE HOW WE DO IN THE
FALL.
OUR JOB RIGHT NOW AND OUR JOB IN
THE WHITE HOUSE TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE READY FOR ANYTHING THAT
HAPPENS IN THE FALL.
WHETHER IT’S TESTING, WHETHER
IT’S PPE.
WHETHER IT’S VENTILATORS.
WHETHER IT’S A COMPLETE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM THAT
UNDERSTANDS THAT WE HAVE TO
TRACK FOR ASYMPTOMATICS AS WELL
AS ASYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS.
ALL OF THOSE PIECES NEED TO
ACCELERATE, EXPAND AND BE READY
FOR THE FALL.
BRIAN: DR. BIRX, THANKS SO MUCH.
WE WILL SEE YOU TODAY AT 5:00,
WE THINK, IF THERE IS A